why is it that when a man cheat He
Cheats he's a cheater but when a woman
cheats she's not satisfied in the
relationship
because can we women cheat emotionally
and men cheat because there's a hole in
the wall
right that's why men cheat sounds like
an excuse me no no I'm just saying
listen it's a corn category right it's
called glory holes you see men putting
their things in they don't care who's on
the other side they're just trying to
get their rocks off right men can do
that men don't care right women actually
for a woman to cheat on a man she has to
be somewhat emotionally involved
questions
men can do it without having any
emotions yeah yeah no but the question
was different though yeah that's not
what I am fast no but you said why no I
said why why does society label the man
a cheater but a woman's not satisfied in
the relationship so why is there an
excuse for for the woman but there's not
an excuse me because it's an account no
it's an accountability issue I agree
it's accountability issue for sure
listen at the end of the day one of the
things that we open up with is that
there's
um systems put in place for whatever
reason to continue to Pander to the
modern woman and I think it's all just
kind of just based off of money I think
that if you want to sell ad placements
to the
the component of the population that
makes eighty percent of the household
purchasing decisions you're going to do
so in a way to try to make them feel
good and nice inside and avoid all
accountability at the end of the day
accountability doesn't feel good having
to fix problems doesn't feel good it's
time intensive and it brings you a dose
of reality of the things that you have
to do to over encumber that right women
don't want to do all that [__] they just
want to just want to feel good about
themselves and let it be the man's issue
or the man's problem like again they're
not focus on Solutions generally but
that's the thing as well say as a man
you need to say accountability for
something and say you seem upset or
distraught about it there is nothing
more disgusting than a dude who doesn't
take accountability exactly it's nasty
but get away from me I don't even want
guy friends who don't take
accountability but get away from me but
me personally as a man who do you go to
to talk to about it because personally I
don't have anyone I don't know about the
other men but I know you don't have
mentors
I'm people I think of mentors but not
people that I would go to emotionally to
talk about my problems as as a man you
sit there and deal with them yourself
but I know all women mates and my Mrs
mates and so on where if they're in
trouble something went wrong whatever
and there's oh my God only talk to
someone about this we're just about 10
15. oh if I was alive he's all right
yeah why can't you go to your father
I don't know we have this stuff no we
have a we have a great leadership he's
um he's role model in some ways but he
has his own problems that I don't wanna
you don't want to go and bother someone
else with your problem so then is it no
I I don't know my number one is my pops
if things are right like my pops
um you know he's my example of what to
be a man in modern day society today is
especially you know being a black man in
America he is my example and I make sure
that big decisions that are within my
life of things that I may not know the
answers to and I consider myself a
genuinely sometimes most of the times a
wise guy you know but for things that
you know I just can't quite figure out
and make sure that I go to him now I
know at the same time there's a lot of
young men out there that don't have that
Father Figure and actually I think
that's a large degree in a component
that's why channels like mine have blown
up is because there's a lot of men young
men out there that might have been
raised in a single parent household that
have questions regarding things that are
happening to themselves with within
their lives that they don't quite have
the answer to so I'm actually surprised
to hear that your father is as active
what he is but you don't go to him it
might be different between England and
America but from over where I'm from in
Southampton pretty much every guy that I
know would say the same as me so maybe
it's uh I don't know a difference do you
think culture are you saying that
culturally men are taught not to say
anything then
growing up in schools yet I think it was
always man up get on and do this sort
this out and I think that's the struggle
men go through and the men can actually
see what it is that's what it is what
you guys understand is that women relate
emotionally like we can empathize and so
when a woman goes through something or
she cheats we we feel this we can we try
to like bring empathy to what she what's
going on with her men are you know are
more logical in their thinking and
deductive reasoning this goes into
biology and and how men's Brains are
wired so logically women will always try
to you know there's confirmation bias as
well because there are other women so
like we we wouldn't give an excuse to a
woman who sleeps with our husband or our
man and like we got a problem with that
but if it's our girlfriend someone we
like or someone in The Sisterhood
there's this kind of like this
camaraderie men do it as well men feel a
camaraderie for each other so but I will
say overall men are much more you know
like they're gonna men are made to to
discipline men are made they're not
going to get into the emotions of like I
don't like my father I don't care what
you felt what did you do like like quit
the quit the crying quit the tears I get
it you feel this way but you have real
world consequences and I think most
women are either treated like princesses
by their fathers or they don't have
accountability growing up they don't
know what it looks like and this is why
they're offended by it and if something
happens to another woman we want to be
understanding because we automatically
empathy puts us in their shoes like we
could see how they feel because we may
have felt a certain way even if we've
never done that action but it doesn't
excuse it away they still need to be
held accountable but that's why so many
women Buck against conversations like
this because it's like how dare you say
something is all these men and men and
women cheat at almost the same rate but
yet it's always men women but actually
Maggie I wonder what were you shaking
your head at uh yeah I mean you you said
a few things there Melanie some I agree
with I think we ended up where we agreed
but I think ultimately men have the
burden of Duty and honor put on them
that women don't and so to answer your
question as to why a man would be
labeled a cheaters because you're
supposed to do right where a woman is
coddled and kind of given well the there
there which I don't agree with we can
still empathize and still call it wrong
for example back to the other point if
I'm speeding through a traffic light
because my son is in an accident I'm
trying to get to the hospital I go
through a red light it's still wrong I
may explain the reason why but if I have
to pay a ticket for it I pay a ticket
for it where we are it's like oh I
understand go ahead and you know go
scot-free so that's what I wanted to say
what are what do you think of this
conversation I I think um
one of the things that you said is kind
of the the empathy of
um women
um and why you guys you know kind of
communicate like that and I often think
like you know I you know if I think I
like like the entrance of like a
therapist is I would say a lot more
beneficial to most modern women than
they are to Modern Men depending upon
the type of therapist that you go to I
think men should go to male therapists
but the thing is is like the downfall of
a lot of modern women today outside of
the Sims the white Knights is other
modern women that are unwilling to hold
them accountable and they'll get into
these Echo chamber circles and just
Kumbaya around the totally incorrect
thing and that's why right like I I
suggest and you know Kevin used to do it
as well too suggest therapy to a lot of
modern women because they can get a
third party arbitrator to understand the
situation and be like do you know one of
those things to be the Bearer in the bad
news however you know what's wrong you
know one of the reasons why they do that
M2
competition
women see each other as competition
women never give each others the keys to
the game okay so when older women get
older right they never give younger
women the game because the older women
are actually vying for the same types of
men that the younger women are vying for
right and so you never ever tell your
opponent the key to the game you can
consult them oh my baby you're so bad is
that what you've done oh my God amazing
but the same types of men that the older
women want the same types of men that
the younger women want so the older
women are never going to give you the
game because they see you as competition
yeah I want to talk about there earlier
Pearl and I were talking about that
earlier I want to come back to you baby
because you aren't you aren't talking
much do you feel do you have older women
in your life that hold you accountable
um well I actually hold myself
accountable no no no no no one can hold
you you can't hold yourself accountable
because we're our own like if you don't
have outside voice we just see ourselves
how we see ourselves accountability
comes from someone saying listen
accountability hurts we don't hurt
ourselves we don't tell ourselves the
things that we need to hear you're
dating a guy you like him and an older
woman say
I see this is going on I see like this
guy is not you know that you can trust
and know that she's not competing with
you do you have an older woman in your
life yeah definitely you know um some of
my mom's friends when I was a bit more
open with my relationship they would
always like throw things at me like oh
if he does this oh he's probably
cheating things like that and it's just
I could tell you know they were in
competition and they just didn't want me
to be happy so definitely really well
it's like so they actually tried to put
your relationship and your man down did
you feel like they were trying to they
they their negativity or their negative
experiences they were trying to put on
you extremely negative they would just
it would just always be something and
then now I'm very very private with my
relationship and just private with my
life but like they've never met him so
it's like how how do you have so much to
say so
do you have anybody a woman an older
woman who says I love you the only thing
I want is the best for you they're not
in competition they're not trying to put
negativity they want to hear what you
have to say they want to meet him love
on him and actually get the real thing
do you have any woman in your life like
that that's older okay so this is a
failure
Maggie what we talked about just on her
podcast we did yesterday older women we
have failed younger women like her I'm
41. you just you're about to turn 21.
yeah like we're 20 years you know like
mothers as well I sometimes feel like
mothers in competition with their
daughters absolutely yeah we just talked
about do you feel as though and I don't
want to put your mother on the spot or
anything you can talk in general but do
you find like what your friends or your
experience that the moms they put like a
competition they don't want you to win
because they failed yeah Stephanie and
and they and they will talk you into
failure right don't don't worry about it
they will console you though right but
but they'll talk you into failure and
then once you fail they'll be like oh
it's okay baby and like I said it's for
it's a if in my personal point of views
for competition about men because the
same man that is going for the 21 year
old that was the 21 year old he will
sleep with you too Melanie right yeah
in a misery loves company yeah it's like
when you when you fail a test what
what's the best feeling in the world
when you turn to someone and they're
like yeah
the class that
Circle that failed I actually know it on
Tick Tock like it would there was a
group of like moms and they did like the
mom content and then one gets divorced
and the other gets divorced and the
other gets to it's like the whole damn
friend group and it's just like misery
really loves company they don't want to
be alone in their bad decisions single
women keep single women single right
right if the older women have not kept
their own relationship together then
it's really hard to wish that uh
blessing on someone else so I think you
have to be very selective and find
someone that is in a relationship that
you actually admire and they're secure
in that relationship I think if you're
trying to get advice from older single
women that's where it can really go live
but sometimes married women as well
because how many married women do we
know wish they could be back in the
streets right that's miserable
I know so many who are just like they
see the glamor of being flown to Dubai
and they don't know they're getting
flown they single again flown to Dubai
because they're laying down with a
camera you're getting flown and blown no
no no that flown and blown that is what
is going on they're actually selling but
we don't because what happens is younger
guys that you may be what's the oldest
guy you've dated
well this is my well second boyfriend
and he's 23. okay yeah so he's not that
much older yeah but that same 23 year
old will try to
will sleep with and go after someone my
age is he serious this happens every day
but I say to myself like so what happens
is these older women will feel like okay
well that little 20 something year old
she can't do nothing for you boo let's
come over here and I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna put it on you she's not grown
she's immature this is how these older
women are thinking these cougars and so
they see you as competition instead of
loving on you and wanting you to win or
they'll use shaming language like
calling the dude a pedo when it's just
like no he just likes younger women yeah
it's and but when they were younger
creepy or he's crazy I don't know a
single older woman who when she was
younger did not date an older guy but
once they get older it's like oh well I
was naive then I didn't know and all
this other stuff so like yeah I dated an
older guy but it's it really was abusive
and I'm just thinking to myself will you
really abused dating an older guys
Financial abuse credit card right they
feel that way and and that's why I
wanted to talk to her because I said as
a younger woman like you know this is
our whole conversation Maggie we were
talking about this yesterday about older
women are competing for the same men
they don't realize that the older women
think because these men will your
boyfriend I'm not saying he is but your
boyfriend will sleep with a woman who's
older and so they think they're in
competition with you and they have to
prove this but they should have been out
the game a long time ago you can see in
The Tick Tock videos right when you see
like mother and daughters right and the
mother looks quite young
that's your competition right there and
it's like the mother's trying to keep up
with her yes but on the flip side men
like MTR men like myself right we may be
older we're trying to give younger men
the game we're trying to say look young
guys this is what you do this is what
you don't do right this older guys what
I've realized older guys don't mind
giving younger guys a game they won't
they don't mind telling them where they
went wrong okay I don't mind telling a
young the guy where I went wrong do you
know what I mean and generally generally
dudes if you're in competition of
another with another dude usually it's
more brute strength fruit uh you know
and competition physically uh downright
to fighting status financials uh
generally women compete utilizing
manipulation innuendo uh reputation
destruction
um we're not giving you the keys to
whatever it is that you're trying to do
right because women don't generally
fight just based off of right like
physical power s but there's other
things that they do Wonder right women
aren't holding each other accountable
but it also sounds like we aren't
holding men accountable right that they
are able to go and do these things with
multiple women and attract to that right
so why are we so why is that our
standard I have a question so um are you
aware that one one in three men are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year yes given the weight that
women date and things like that yep what
percent of men do you think are sexually
active in sleeping with multiple women
hmm
I think it's like 30 or 40 or something
it's five to ten percent yeah so it's
like you're gonna put five to ten
percent of men's decisions on all of all
on all of men when really it's like 80
of women that are sleeping with them
amen that's it so I'm thinking women
need to take the accountability right so
so it's who's it more on women for sure
that's what I was posing that women
aren't holding women accountable but the
men the five to ten percent of men that
are out doing that they're doing it with
all of the 87 and we aren't holding them
accountable but the women should they
because the women are throwing
themselves right like Drake like what
these girls are these girls are waiting
well back to the question wrong is wrong
right no no no no
you can't hold Men wrong for developing
themselves to be as best as what they
positively and ultimately can be and
then they get all of this coochie thrown
at them okay the concept
concept of groupie is a strictly female
term it's not it on the flip side right
so like I I think like listen at the end
of the day there's a whole media engine
put in the place to hold men accountable
I don't want no scrubs scrub is a God
for me
[Music]
come on come on and on top of that on
the flip side they got the women singing
about being Miss Independent I don't
cook I don't clean all of these things
that don't hold them accountable for
being a good marriageable wife
same women though are actually wives or
want to be wives but they're telling us
like I don't cook I don't clean them for
the street city girls the city girls are
talking about we're independent but then
you're so desperate for a man the
benefits of being modern and not the
consequences of being modern they want
the benefits of being modern and the
benefits of being conservative or
traditional at the same damn time while
a whole media engine is have been
holding men accountable since TV was TV
since love connection was on the goddamn
TV screen and all up until today the
music the TV not YouTube because we hold
them accountable over here and every
other forms of media the movies the
Disney they've been holding guys
accountable since the beginning of time
to talk shows shout out to Steve Harvey
shout out to the Derrick Jacksons y'all
been holding guys accountable now we
have platforms today where men can hold
women accountable and y'all get mad as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible